I promised we'd be picking up right from
where we left off this morning which was
on the equation of the tangent of the
normal okay now we're gonna zoom in on
the tendon because things are so awesome
so many cool things that come out from
them I'm gonna show you one of the most
interesting new brands flaming results
okay so let's on let's get down the
equation of a tangent
like I said we're remembering them not
for the sake of career but so that when
you use them you recognize them right
now if I want the tangents at a point
say P it's Grady is going to be P all
right so it's gonna start like this and
that funny unusual thing we noticed
about the y-intercept is that it
corresponds exactly to the y coordinate
of the point where you're coming from
right like you're coming from two AP AP
squared AP squared and you're hitting
the y-axis at - April it's quite
dangerous okay so here's the first
interesting we're going to look at which
one sort of reveal the power of Y these
ways of saying the equations are so
useful if this is a tangent at pain what
might be the equation of a tangent at Q
it's better yeah QX - no big deal okay
now anytime mathematicians get their
hold of a new tool a new way to
represent things what kinds of things
can we do with this okay now if you've
got two tangents at two different points
P and Q being distinct one of the most
natural questions that kind of flows out
that is well where did these two
tangents intersect okay where do the
tangents intersect this ends up being
the kind of question that says you want
a bit of a sends you down a rabbit hole
but you get all these interesting things
out of it as a result okay so where are
the two tangents intersect that's the
question we're going to ask now just on
the face of it if I said I've got a
straight line I've got a straight line
right I know there's P's and Q's in the
midst of fire but they're just numbers
they're just constants of some kind of
what would you do just off the base of
it to find where they intersect I'm just
gonna solve them simultaneously right
and being that both of them have why is
the subject I might as well just make
these two equal to each other like so
now once I solve this because I've
eliminated Y out of the equation right
I'm going to get values for or a value
Rama for X that's the x-coordinate of
where the tangents intersect and using
that you can find a y-coordinate off you
go and take a couple minutes you want to
solve for X right so therefore I've got
X is over here X over there you want to
get stuff on the right side so I would
do this over here and then just place
that AP squared over the other side a PT
squared and that - a q squared is still
hanging around okay
now I can do a lot with this there's
loads of things to factorize right over
the left hand side I'm going to take out
the X thanks over on the right hand side
I can do two things I can take out the a
and then I can also do the difference
that you spend so I've got P minus Q P
plus Q okay now at this point I can do
some grand cancelling but why what am I
getting cancer I'm gonna cancel P minus
Q and the reason why I can the reason I
can divide both sides by this is because
it's not zero because P and Q are not
the same there are two different places
okay so I'm going to divide through and
I just get left with this okay that's
nice and neat isn't it
okay once you take this you can pop this
into any of these equations right and
you're going to get a Y value out of it
right so this is X if I say Y use pop in
the top one you let do
yeah so far so good
there's an AEP squid hanging out the
front there plus an AP q and then that
AP squared manatee spin cancel out
leaving you with this okay sir
excuse me let's pause for a second like
what does this mean I've gone next year
and I got a why here so now I have a
point of intersection of the two
tangents wherever the tangents are the
answer to this question where do the
tangents intersect years at hey Q comma
a P - that's the point of intersection
okay now just like before once you get a
result you want to push on it a little
bit and see if it yields you any
insights okay for instance for instance
I want you to have a look at the right
hand son board I want you to remember
this morning and before your ap Tunes we
were looking at the equation of the
chord right now we did just prove the
equation before we noticed some
interesting things about it for instance
if the chord passes through the focus it
passes through the focus if it's a chord
so we called it up local court right the
focus at least you want your sort of
classic focus it has the coordinates 0 a
right so if we pop this into the
equation of the court I remember I
wonder if you remember what results um
here's a right there's a where does the
zero come in
it just makes this term disappear do you
remember that do you get this okay and
then you divide through by - play and
out pops this guy okay now what does
that mean do you know what that means
it means the equations of the tangents
sorry the gradients of the tangents they
multiply minus one which means the
tensions themselves are perpendicular
okay the tangents themselves they
intersect at this point huh but hold on
a second this tells us even more it
tells us not only are the tenants
perpendicular but PQ is
right yeah so if the tangents on the
ends of these are the tangents right are
on the ends of a Corbett pastures for
the folks so if they're on the ends of
the focal court if the tangents are on
the ends of a focal court right then I
can say where do the tangents intersect
PQ is negative one right so therefore I
can say they intersect at this point I
might as well replace this with this
because I can get rid of because Q is
just minus 1 over P comma P Q is
negative 1
- hey what's that - eh that's the
directrix right we did this we animate
and we saw that that point of
intersection it always lay on that
bottom line okay so here's a quick
picture in case you can't remember this
parabola keys out directories down with
you okay if you pick out a Koi that goes
through looks like the focus is roughly
there okay so he's a focal chord right
let's put some tangents into these
things for something like this
we know two things sorry it's a bit
rough the change is going to be
perpendicular but no earlier they
perpendicular the locus of points traced
out by the point of intersection is the
directrix in fact that's an alternative
definition of the directory's right
it's the locus of points traced out by
the points of intersection they're these
angels okay so long as they sit on the
opposite ends of the focal Court okay